we have talked about what appears to be
a contradiction between being a
so-called Christian and supporting
Donald Trump and it doesn't make sense
if one calls themself a Christian to
support Donald Trump and there's a
number of reasons why and we've talked
about it there was a six-person panel on
CNN six Trump voters were brought in and
the entire thing was insane
truly depraved and insane but there was
one particularly whacky portion of it
where a guy was asked at rent these are
all Trump voters one guy was asked and
this was the guy who was most strongly
still in the tank for Trump Trump could
do no wrong in the eyes of this guy who
were gonna hear from in a moment he said
that if he heard from Jesus himself that
Trump colluded with Russia he would
first want to go and talk to Trump about
it he would not take Jesus's word over
Donald Trump's and of course many of the
people in my audience would say well why
would anybody take Jesus's word you have
to remember in the universe of these
people the idea that if they heard from
Jesus they would still check with Trump
is pretty stunning take a look at this
video listen to the audio let me tell
you if Jesus Christ gets down off the
cross and told me Trump is with Russia I
will tell him hold on a second I need a
check with the president if it's true
why everybody else why I believe in him
he's a good man he has taken so much
shots for us yeah maybe this is a good
thing right like the guy's not so
ideologically committed to Christianity
that he'd believe a regular old human
over the supposed Son of God but at the
same time maybe he sees Trump as God and
that's why he would take Trump's word
over Jesus's word this guy actually made
the other five panelists look slightly
reasonable like the other five panelists
during the six person thing seemed to
have some signs of regret or buyer's
remorse or hesitation about what Donald
Trump has done but not this guy and and
guys like this or why I don't believe
there's really any hope for trumpets at
large or on mass to ever turn around see
the error
of their ways and that's why I've been
advising I mean really since the
election that we should forget about
these people in terms of winning
elections right if you're gonna see
people like this at Thanksgiving will
hear from Pat about whether he's gonna
have people like this arguing this
vociferous leaf or trumpet Thanksgiving
if you want to debate them for the fun
of it Pat wants to have debates at
Thanksgiving during vegan Thanksgiving I
don't know if you want to waste your
time or not but if you want to do it go
ahead have at it Hoss but from a voting
standpoint get out the vote for
progressives and moderates who don't
typically vote that is a much more
effective use of your time because
you're not gonna convince guys like this
that Trump is terrible for them and
terrible for America that's the one good
thing right which is that because voter
turnout is typically so low in American
elections we can defeat these people
without having to convince these people
of anything just based on voter turnout
but we have to do it right that's the
thing and the midterms aren't exactly
the time for massive voter turnout or
high voter enthusiasm my only hope is
that because everything is different
in the trump era that there actually
will be circumstances and an environment
where we will see more engagement for
progressives and left-leaning moderates
during the midterms we can completely
marginalize this group of total
extremists but it's going to take action
it's going to take activism and one
effect of the Russian Twitter BOTS and
sort of the pro-trump fake news sites
and everything else has been it makes us
think that Trump BOTS like this guy are
way more common than they are and the
truth is yes there are millions and
millions of them but they aren't that
common when you consider the entire
voting age population of the United
States and we need to activate those
other people particularly those that are
not voting can you imagine if guys like
this were the majority or even the
plurality in our country it's truly
disturbing but the only silver lining
and it's been tough
Pat's done a good job of finding a
somewhat somewhat strange but silver
line it linings nonetheless I've been
trying to find silver linings in the
trump era one of them is that on voter
turnout alone
we can defeat these people and scary
stuff I encourage you to watch the full
six person Trump voter panel on CNN
incredibly disturbing the stuff of
nightmares